before we get into this episode of
fighter and the kids with my boys
chappelle lacey and malik b a few
housekeeping notes for you west palm
beach
improv florida get your tan asses to
west palm beach
december 31st through january 2nd me and
the crew
will be out there uh bringing new year's
the right way 2021
no better way to bring it in with me and
the boys west palm beach florida
let's ride also just announced just
dropped san marcos texas january 29th
through the 30th it's four shows to
friday to
saturday me and very special guests
in texas san marcos texas right outside
austin right outside san antonio
it's at a place called the mark
uh yeah we'll be there these tickets
will sell out so get on them now
don't be upset when they sell out san
marcos texas
january 29th through the 30th tickets at
t5k.com
and this friday at midnight thick boy
gear
drops the smiley thick boy hoodie you
see me wearing
we got another color dropping we got
shirts dropping sweats
hats smiley boy thick boyd uh my
favorite design we've done yet
you see the smiley face all up on the
videos the bieber videos
the marshmallow videos well there's
nothing to represent us thick boys
and now there is it's the thick boy
smiley face merch drops this friday at
midnight thick boy.com
coming in hot hey i like the thick boy
merch son
yeah yeah i mean i mean he's i'm just
really looking good these days i want
the jersey i'm waiting for my jersey
you still have the jersey dude when
something's about to drop like i'm like
teasing it you're
just in a elliott would be like dude i
need that l like
size large or medium where the [ __ ]
you're wearing oh justin's on top
he gets all the new [ __ ] oh dude
you asked me like months later like damn
dog i need a large one
sold out no no listen you showed me the
merch before i'm like oh that's hot
brenden i mean i'm here's my address
she's like no worries no you've never
given me your address
i have no idea where you live you know
you listen what about this [ __ ] drops
friday
the new fat boy smiles damn look at that
smiley face
yeah everybody bieber marshmallow trying
to do their own smiley face i would say
where's the fat boy smiling does that
mean i got a fat
ass smiley face i ain't rocking them
slim faces slim faces
those stick boy faces yeah keep it
[ __ ] thick
how was uh phoenix boys with joe coy you
open up for joey
and it was great great did was he's a
great dj there yep
it's dj ryan man it's so [ __ ] whoa
whoa he goes out to us
and it's just it's exciting but i mean
it was um
it's like he's he was talking we were
talking about stage and it's a little
tough for him
like doing the clubs because he's an
arena guy now yeah you know what i mean
so like when he does a club
like uh this was his first club back he
uh
he just a lot of people shout at clubs
yeah they just shouted at him and like
for him like you know
an arena you can't hear that [ __ ] yeah
theater you really can't hear it either
yeah and he has such great bits that are
just
you know everybody loves so much oh is
he doing he's doing some
classic bits
go ahead i'm this your brother oh my god
he didn't have anything he didn't have a
[ __ ] plan at all
oh he's just going up there yeah he was
like i'll do an hour and a half
well no with nothing no plan yeah no
killed every building monster it was
just fine
found stuff you know find it found stuff
everybody
about like found you know stuff
throughout the whole nuggets throughout
the whole throughout the whole yeah
hour and a half mm-hmm it was dope huh
you know what else don't watch them go
go go at these hecklers oh my god
they were hecklers listen listen like
talking [ __ ] he's just he's just so
big yeah he's he's so famous he's just
so i can't even
even kevin hart i'm sure because he does
clubs getting ready for his hour
yeah i'm sure like if rogan does it i'm
sure people are screaming [ __ ] out
they're just screaming [ __ ] out you get
annoyed like where's the elk you know
you're like
where's the l or the m you saw me the
funniest thing you shouted
how about in nashville and that's where
that guy yelled at
talk about a five oh yeah at the end of
my bed i'm like what
yeah he didn't stomp on her did he no
you won't tell him oh never mind what
about a girl stumped on a jokoy bit
oh he's they were wild huh yeah dude
i mean did he did did people come around
bamboo sticks and hit them because
they're asian crowds
brittany it wasn't pacquiao what the
heck i don't know how they did
i don't know how they're kind of
culturally accurate yeah they
get my ass beat with a bamboo stick yeah
that's right those things are
they [ __ ] hurt that's just the thing
that you don't know about them until you
get
whipped with one is that you feel it
before you hear it
wait what you can like yeah like you
feel the um
bamboo stick hit your skin before you
ever hear it coming
whereas like if you like like a belt you
could hear yeah like a bell you can hear
right away when it hits
i never heard the bell with my mind with
me the speed of the
sound i believe is slower than the speed
of the bamboo stick hitting you yeah so
the point is joe coy should have a bunch
of
big i'm talking real this is curious
asians that in every row
just beating people people go [ __ ] do
this big
he's just an all-out beast man on stage
joe it was my favorite people
yeah and um you know and how did you do
with the all-asian crowd
great it was great i can't i could
confirm you went
you oh you went to jail and you but you
met joe oh well you met john
they clowned me every day about my role
oh right every time he walked in the
room
joe did yeah and it's so funny you know
that uh uh
[ __ ] biggie song with uh diddy when
they're gonna throw your rollies in oh
yeah
it was playing as soon as joe walked in
the green room because he was already in
there
and he just walked over
waving that badass rolly yeah
yeah he has he has a shoe collection too
yes oh as far as comedy goes kicks it's
joe coy chris and me
yeah the whole weekend oh yeah he
dresses dope dude
his uh his team that he that he rolls
with is great like everybody's just
super [ __ ] you see his merch team
with his sister running this register
yeah
did you get someone's merch merch game
strong i'm surprised you didn't get what
do you mean
no you don't like it i didn't say that
oh yeah yeah
no no oh word yeah but uh i'm sorry the
other person i bully for merch
yeah you do bullying me up out of his
house
i said what you got in the garage
walk me down
did you post any pictures really no wow
that's a big event though oh it was such
a great you didn't post any picture with
joey
open him for him no unbelievable well
they uh they had a guy taking pictures
jacob shout out no one sent you a pic no
not yet are you gonna post when you get
a pic yeah of course
okay i was gonna say dawg god damn no
don't be acting too cool for joe boy
it's whatever i was just it was listen
was i not just chilling reserved
oh yeah respecting the whole i know he
was chill because when they was telling
the story
and then the guy called him blackie and
then joe coy cal it gave him
he didn't call me black black no he did
it no he didn't
see no no he didn't don't do that to him
well malek sent a group tag
[Applause]
tell them how when you're in the green
room some guy called you black yeah
i put goddamn blackie yeah don't you put
these people out there like that
because give me content exactly
because it sounded racist no it was
either way you go no it was his friend
his friend was named
blacky that was oh yeah was he black
it was a white guy named blackie yes it
wasn't
and it wasn't even joe's friend you
needed good that's funny now
yeah it is funny jackass
yeah so i got there friday night he
already had been doing shows
yeah he was i think he started wednesday
he said tuesday
oh he started tuesday 10 10 shows oh
okay
jesus christ yeah 10 shows so he had two
shows each night
but like the sunday they started earlier
so the first show was at 6 pm oh word
yes it it's actually pretty nice so
stand up live you all some [ __ ] you
let joe coy sell merch
oh i forgot about that yeah palm beach
i'm selling [ __ ]
i was wondering because she set up she
had a hole and then they have a little
yeah they were excelling i'm like god
damn oh you know what
uh another big thing of the weekend
how good did i eat oh i was so sweet
what
yeah he couldn't he cut you off for real
he cut you off for real
like liz i thought it was a joke a game
i told you seriously what
you're done over here in these streets
just all
dude going all healthy options egg
whites we were going to hit the gym
together and then
oh yeah and then i realized we didn't
have the [ __ ] gym shoes
but he's seen him work he's serious yeah
he said damn you've been eating healthy
did you feel better hey did you what
he was even testing me throwing [ __ ] at
me you want canes oh they're raising
canes
you guys didn't go to tj's though no i
can't the [ __ ] wrong with you bro
listen i'm not dj's though yeah that is
true come on yeah
i can do the wings yeah oh yeah can i do
wings chin do you know yeah can we
confirm with the asian community
wings are good though as long as it
doesn't have breading all that stuff on
it
oh yeah those wings they're not breaded
those are like there's some sugar on
them though now
i know that teriyaki
how about joe uh text me goes guess
where i'm at i was like [ __ ] jt's
he's all
no what was that i felt so fast
i thought maybe you took him there so
he's like no
oh yeah no that's stupid
it's my favorite place you can do this
great yeah i could have had that though
uh there's a lot of sugar in those wings
that's what i'm saying
and then you dip it in your ass i think
that's a rabbit hole yeah like you kind
of
if you have like grilled wings with real
hot sauce
hot wings zero carbs that's the number
one thing i look at so there's no carbs
sugar you know sugars is carbs that
sauce is sugar that's why i'm addicted
yeah
oh the sauce on it yeah so it all
depends if you just have hot sauce
you're good
we're playing just buffalo oh but that
no ranch or blue cheese either though
why are you pointing at me like that
though because you're looking at it you
can have a finger
you can have them why did you figure it
out before you left we did uh whiskey
pete's
oh yeah we did a whiskey pizza that was
great yeah he was trying to get you to
relapse yeah he's trying to get right
he dropped that speaker next week he
said two weeks i think two weeks i think
before we go to the last week we go oh
that's good
the week of yeah and so we promoted
what's wrong but yeah he was he was so
funny and i hope people don't
give the man [ __ ] for trying to get me
to drink but he he thinks of drink
drinking completely different than the
average person
that's his experience though yeah his is
basically strictly for like taste he's
not trying to get [ __ ] up no
you know like most people like they yeah
they get you know drink or whatever they
they're
they're not doing it for the taste i get
it all for flavor yeah you do it for
yeah you do for flavor you like whiskey
because you like the flavor you like the
way it tastes
you know you like you jameson tonight
because i like what you're feeling yeah
but that was the thing with me like i
wanted to get [ __ ] up so i don't know
how to drink in a way
that he knows how to drink different
yeah it's just different which is all
like i i thought everything he was
saying was like a cool way to like look
at it i don't think people give them
[ __ ] they shouldn't
they shouldn't whiskey yeah exactly and
it has nothing to do with you
[ __ ] it was awesome did you try
that whiskey
chicken speak your truth dude there's a
there's a
app my girl has i didn't know she had
them like how the [ __ ] you have this
where it's just alcohol and they deliver
it within six it's like postmates or
whatever they deliver under an hour
and they have everything on there like i
ordered two bottles of
easy i say it uh nico whiskey n-i-k-k-a
seriously what they they dropped the
[ __ ] they came to my house in 30 minutes
oh so oh so it's like a pokemon and you
can pick the other i found the nika
uh coffee whiskey on there which is my
favorite dude
not terrible pricing either they have
everything on it are you like the coffee
whiskey
yeah well it's a coffee grain whiskey
oh god that's my favorite i got two
bottles of that and watched some [ __ ]
love island last night yeah
i cannot get enough of it you don't you
don't like kraken i used to drink kraken
you know what that is like japanese
whiskies you never heard of kraken no i
don't think anyone
i bet you've seen kraken cool yeah look
at that probably the coolest looking box
looks like [ __ ] oil
release the crap that's the big guy yeah
that put a little hair on your chest i
remember that yeah that would be a run
though yeah
uh yeah i think yeah kraken kraken's a
wrong spice drum
great name though and label whiskey
whiskey pete loves you dude i love
whiskey people
yeah he does he yeah he loves you he
talked about it i forgot you knew him
yeah remember in houston y'all did the
podcast and then uh he came to the show
backstage i did the part oh i did yeah
yeah yeah me and brian did it together
and then y'all left me again at the
hotel
and then he came to the show yeah
yeah i do and they came to the show we
behind he was like bro why you just come
with them i was like well they left they
tell me
i forgot you knew him because you should
because he was talking about i'm like
yeah for sure mal should be here to talk
about it not us
yeah yeah
yeah uh a lot of these fans thinking
like yo i'm dissing big sean because he
stole my ex no i'm this
you are okay i'm dissing big shine on my
own volition
all right this is between this is
personal beat yeah i just for every guy
every average guy
that got his girl stolen by like a
superstar yeah exactly so this is not
anything to do with my ex it's me but a
little shot
sure yeah so when you hear the disc on
the 23rd
we heard we heard the death last week
yeah last week you did a little no
no he was writing on his way in here he
was asking me what rhymes with big sean
no i know
i don't know i'm just trying to spit
ball ideas here he's trying to help you
out no because i said
if i say minchon lil sean that rhymes
together yeah i don't know dude i'm not
looking forward to your rap yeah i'm not
looking forward to it either just keep
writing yeah but
we're going we should have had you on
whiskey pete okay okay
yeah yeah he was saying a lot of great
things about you oh thank you i love
wishingp we talk all the time through
the dms oh really yes yeah he's a great
dude yeah
he got he got chance some uh racist
whiskey or something like that
yeah i forgot the name of it but yeah
like night what from the year you were
1977 yeah i was born
called red
we're 10 years apart you 40 wow i'm 43
bro 23
he's the oldest person in here in this
room how crazy is that
yeah when do i close and i don't want to
be racist when do asians like start
showing old age
75 uh for women usually when they hit
menopause metabolism yeah
which is 50. 50 60
i want to say like to a certain extent
we like once we start aging we start
aging very well because it's overnight
oh dude it's like cinderella yeah
midnight hits
when you carve that shoe drops like you
age like fruit
yeah it's a cinderella type of thing
yeah there's an old red box
old red fox but then there's an indian
in the cover did you finish that bottle
too i didn't i'm waiting
for what for what uh i just moved
recently all right i just got a new
apartment oh yeah
yeah good news good answer
don't be telling anybody [ __ ] he's all
yeah no i moved to washington
no i fly in every monday yeah so i
didn't how long have you been doing that
three years
i didn't officially move yet but i got
the apartment so i'm starting what area
next week
marine del rey yeah dude that's
awesome dude i know marina like the back
of my i know i'm gonna actually a lot of
are you are you in a townhouse out there
it's uh
this apartment two-bedroom apartment
because i want to make one area for a
studio
yeah yeah and one room for a studio and
then so too oh for music yeah
oh i just you know when i i work at home
too so it's just easy to edit there
all right since we're talking about new
[ __ ] i gotta ask you come on man
yeah my man got a jeep hey thanks for it
i gotta get that
i'll send you a pick right now hold on
black on black and that just chappelled
so well and it matches with his dad's
car too
about it what it says all right he goes
welcome to the club man
run like
i can't even find an airdrop but they're
you can't find a drug did you just text
it
yeah it takes it too long okay i don't
get why people like your drop [ __ ] just
it's fast
it's faster though it's faster it's
better quality too if you send over a
video oh really yeah yeah
look at you look at all that [ __ ]
look at my man black on black on black
it feels good man my girl's excited man
yeah she's yeah she ain't gotta give me
rides no more oh yeah
though and you got the new crib bro i
swear my girls ride or die bro when we
bro
a couple months into our relationship
what's she saying she she paid my rent
like three times though
that's love that's love she's laughing
like that
it's a sweetheart i paid her bet yeah
it's like an investment yeah it's an
investment yeah
i paid her back like immediately that's
so i'm so three times though you said
you wanted a honda and you got a
wrangler oh no
look at you oh yeah but then yeah you
told me
months ago your favorite car was a jeep
it is yeah cause that's uh
i had a 99 jeep wrangler and uh
that's what i i sold that to move to l.a
yeah i was like i can live without a car
people say it was purple but that [ __ ]
was blue so it's a beautiful symbolic
story
how you sold your [ __ ] is dope yeah yeah
that's yeah it's kind of now did you
pick up malik
yeah well he pulled up to my house and i
drove oh dope
yeah because he don't look too far for
me i'm still in the same class oh yeah
he saw he saw my spot
oh yeah yeah he had to give me a ride i
give it right after whiskey
because i didn't have a car yet i gave
him gas money though
you were all scared and [ __ ] yeah bruh i
[ __ ] hate that car
i hate being in that [ __ ] because he's
well he's just be like
i don't like my backpack i think he
moves it's too big for y'all i gotta get
back to you
he was getting in the car oh
can i move it back and you see the roll
cage back
so how was you sitting just like typing
all up on me dawg all of them means
touching it we just
ate y'all on the date we just yeah yeah
what was that where were we earlier that
[ __ ] uh how long
are we going to pretend bruh y'all
eating her hey this is before this yeah
okay yeah but man we had this croissant
there
it was like nutella there's a christmas
tell over there
now earth to the listeners is spelled
you are no no it's not that one yeah
that's earth oh is it yeah
you are th i think an earth bar right he
got famous
he got famous off of um entourage yes oh
really yeah those hoes used to meet
there during the show
is that exactly where we're at oh really
yep that's where it got right well that
makes sense because there's a lululemon
right next to you yeah yep
that [ __ ] now that's the one off of main
street that's all yeah that's my
favorite one
this is another one it's another one
yeah that one is like maybe three miles
away from yeah close
oh that one's nice that's the main one
yeah that one's dope i just go there all
the time
they're matcha boba is the macho boy
that's a girl put me on that matcha ball
i'm like all right
it's good right yeah chin you're off uh
via marina or via
dolce do you know i don't know exactly
pershing i think pershing's the street
you know pershing
mm-hmm uh-huh 10-minute walk to the
beach ooh
you can fish all the things that's how
much i am trying to walk and go fishing
every day the fish are in the marina del
rio but
there's great whites over there dog i'm
sure there's sharks but usually like
shark
oh yeah i don't like catching sharks
though i like catching stuff i'm gonna
eat
that perch surf person yeah they ate
like a corbina or something like that i
want a new
clown fish or a clown fish you're not
going to catch those over there yeah
like you could even eat clown fish i
heard they don't i think every fish
pretty much
oh really yeah have you had shark i've
had shark
i thought shark did you like it no no
asians have uh shark fin soup
it's like a terrible way of fishing
sharks like they just cut off the fin
and put the rest of the body back in the
ocean a lot of i believe it's like
chinese cuisine
is there anything asians don't eat nope
uh okay no no not really
honestly really are you saying we're
gonna eat everything in anything yeah
it's pretty cool uh listen is your girl
excited about maria del rey or are you
leaving her behind what are you doing
no wait i don't think i said i don't
know he's moving
bro i don't know i don't know what's
going on with him
he's living in baltimore
[Applause]
yeah she's excited
logan paul on food truck diary
congratulations yeah i guess
but he uh that's my guy but he uh
he was like man he's talking about
training partners i was like dude my boy
malik i do the show with he's with floyd
forever
he's like really i was like yeah he can
help out he was connect us
so yeah you would yeah him he's right up
there well the he trains in encino
close by you'll close my eyes okay yeah
wait what's that spot
encino so you know when you go on the
101 the first actually
the the gym out there it's his gym oh
it's his gym oh god
he went before me the youtube uh the joe
coy uh shows
is that his first time doing stand-up
yeah
yeah he says music artist he's a
musician yeah he does a lot
oh he does their podcast too right yes
yep he does their podcast
and he's a host on the podcast yeah yeah
like co-host yeah
yeah cause they had brought him in one
time and then people just really loved
him and
uh he he said they just kept him on and
just you know
his energy is magnetic like i love his
confidence yeah
oh dude that yeah him on stage like his
energy he did well his confidence yeah
he
really like for his first time yeah
really and a joke
yeah it wasn't bad because he he has
such a
great like confidence about himself you
know like
i mean he's slow whatever he's
my bad tyrion's middle eastern though
right i know but he didn't let me talk
i knew exactly he's just he just said
middle eastern you know i mean that's
like so he's
the right asian yeah he does music and
uh
he does everything actually well he just
started stand up but yeah damn
yeah so um that'd be great i think i'm
gonna link up with him and
you know logan yeah we'll try to go over
how not to lose bad against floyd but yo
who was that fighter
the ufc fighter he tried to get down
with oh so
joel can we like listen so joe is so
messy he's kind of like you
right so he will instigate a fight
so george he was like yeah i'll do this
little box i do his mma
right he's like yeah yeah okay you do
uh-huh uh-huh so
jo koy's boy uh mma fighter out of
arizona he was the first
mexican um tell you right now
not brian ortega no no no joe daddy
stevenson no
[ __ ] what was that he's the first what
meg's gonna do something
yeah that that sounds about right who
knows he's got a phoenix
the holiday season is here and holiday
shoppers are buying more stuff
online than ever before nobody going to
the mall
nobody trying to get that disease so
guess what
let ship station help you it's the
fastest easiest most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks your imagine orders
printing out discount shipping labels
getting your products out fast the
result happier holidays for you
and your customers whatever you're
trying to sell shipstation helps online
sellers get orders out
quick save money on shipping and
shipping cost all right
keep the customers happy whether it's
shopify
amazon ebay your own website your own
merch ship
station brings you all your orders in
one simple interface
making it really easy to manage your
orders from any device
especially your cell phone right ship
station works with all the major
carriers including usps
fedex ups even international all right
so you got you covered no wondership
station the number one choice
of online sellers you ship more and less
time with the best rates available
and right now the finally kids listeners
can try shipstation
free for 60 days when you use the offer
code fighter make sure your business can
meet the demands all right
of online shopping this season get
started at shipstation.com
right now click on the microphone top
the home page type in fighter that's
shipstation.com
then enter the offer code fighter
shipstation.com make ship
happen listen kids there's nobody on the
planet like you so why would you sleep
on a planet built for everybody else
you need to get helix sleep helix sleep
has a quiz that you take it takes two
minutes
you complete it they match a mattress to
your perfect body type
side sleeper hot sleeper body sleeper
stomach sleeper whatever you are we got
you covered we got a mattress
just for your thick ass helix sleep was
even awarded the number one best overall
mattress
uh in 2019 and 220 by gq and wired
magazine
i have in my house i can't get rid of my
in-laws can't get rid of my
brother-in-law
my brother wants to stay over because
they love these freaking mattresses
just go to helixsleep.com fighter take
their two minute sleep quiz
and then we'll match you with a custom
mattress just for you for the best
sleeper of your life
they have a 10 year warranty you get to
try out for 100 nights risk free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will so don't
worry about that
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses
all right and free pillows for you
finally kids
listeners go to helixsleep.com fighter
that's helix sleep dot com slash fighter
for up to two hundred dollars off
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com fighter
um his name is hold on he came to the
show joe following
all right he's in the ufc currently yes
he's back soon
yes and he's uh he's not yet here right
what's his name yeah rodriguez
what's that that kind of sounds familiar
anyways was he handsome yeah good
looking he was a good looking guy
out of arizona it might be what was it
the guy on the right malik wait let me
see
let me uh let me get his picture hold on
hold on come on
because the guy posted i don't really
speak english though
he does he does well not great not
amazing but
is that him is that him let me see [ __ ]
was it that guy
i mean this guy yeah that's him
rodriguez that's i think that's him oh
this [ __ ] said
yes look it looks like he's following
he's following he's following y'all
right now
was there yeah he's having issues with
the ufc
oh should we not no everyone knows
oh yeah that was the first thing that
pogba
yeah that's what we're following yeah
yeah that's pretty boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah battle he's out
of arizona
is he out of arizona i don't know if
he's out here though well he was out
there
so what's uh so so either way the guy
was like okay
cool so after the show joe as soon as he
walked in he was like yo joe that was
amazing yeah yeah hold up
this guy said he can fight hillary he
wants to fight and he's like nah joe i
don't wanna and
he was like nah let's do the face off
you please when they did a face they did
a face-off
the whole staff outside so you know
outside of tempe improv they have the
green room
and they have this in the lobby in the
lobby area and they had everyone the
staff and
they had head to head yeah they were
like doing like their whole head their
head were they
that the open i mean uh
see a smaller guy yeah he's married this
fighter was smaller
yeah he was smaller they were like the
same size yeah
he's not huge he's taller though yeah
yeah he was a little bit he was a little
taller than him
he fights at 145 though he's a smaller
guy yes so it might be him that's what
i'm saying i don't know this is english
not great
we didn't know we just showed us the
video and they just stared down
head-to-head
and then it was getting intense he just
took it he took down uh
oh yeah uh joe coy's weird i wonder if
it was yay
i know i'm i'm super curious now yeah
you guys can't find out no i can't
remember
i [ __ ] wish you guys could figure it
out i know because we don't know who
you're talking about
i'm sorry y'all can yeah yeah you should
do a stare down
oh right now oh no we already uh he and
i already actually already fought
who won he did chappelle tapped himself
out
and brendan thought he killed you yeah i
know jay had to go hey
that is true that was that was before
you was on this diet like now you're
training you're in shape
you want to die for one day it's not
getting one day
i did good the whole week the whole week
and he's been working out before this
okay wow i'm rooting for you
now you you hey you know
how about me and my girl watching uh
love island oh everybody bodied up on
that show everybody bought it
and we got done eating and we ate pretty
healthy we had salad with salmon
and then i have my favorite ice cream i
sent out eating ice cream they brought
in a new boy to the house and this boy
was
shred city oh really so i just quietly
put my ice cream back my groove goes you
know you eat your ice cream
so you're trying to ah loosely loosely
last night was more of a shame thing
that i passed it up but
yeah it'd be nice to get in shape that's
all i know see we got this yeah we just
can't do it together
why not it's better if you do it
well now that you're doing it i have to
do
there's no there's not good food in palm
beach anyway well don't say that i mean
listen i get it like not compared to
where we go you just sent me three
places
where oh what is florida known first of
all stevie finds
stevie blue eyes finds something healthy
on every [ __ ] menu that is true hold
up stevie doesn't count why you know
stevie did prison time stephen stevie's
eating
eggs i'm with you raw spinach
listen i'm gonna be on a diet i'm not
eating like stevie
i enjoy life you know what i'm saying
i'm just saying he ate like hey stevie's
out
i don't want to be on stevie's diet so i
like stevie's diet
stevie's diet pisses me off dude when we
go every time we go to the store
and he gets hard boiled eggs
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag
you know i have a condition uh meno uh
uh it's been kind of what it was an
ophelia or something like that but
people eating food triggers me and
[ __ ]
stevie dude trying to watch love eyelash
here
oh yeah i was like you need the chips
like that the whole time
dude oh you're talking about someone's
smile i hate that i almost got that
mobile yeah yeah yeah
metal fission oh huh
miss misophonia
what were we saying he's sophonius
misophonia yes ocd um
yeah anyways but yeah he finds something
healthy every time we go
we don't want that life dude that's too
extreme see stevie
i'm all in i'm not all in on that life
stevie had cancer
we don't want oh my god
[Applause]
a seven year stint of hard times
stevie stevie still wakes up in the
morning like there's roll call in prison
we don't want that life wait wait i
notice how clean stevia is on the road
yeah his toothbrush is to the side yeah
he folds his hand towel i'm like bro
you can relax with an airbnb they clean
it i know right they clean this i think
a good medium is eating how
malakites because mal looks in good
shape but he doesn't eat clean like
stevie
correct yeah yeah well he had canes like
one what was it one day yeah yeah one of
the ideas yeah you guys should just copy
what malik does
yeah and he uh he he offered me a chip
chicken tender too oh he didn't take it
didn't
[Applause]
i'm
[Applause]
no what we should do is bat what's that
if money's involved i'll stick to the
dollar okay
listen how much were we talking right i
don't know what are you thinking yeah
i'm not gonna lie though the red vines
smell good and [ __ ] that's why i opened
it it's not really nothing like a red
vine
damn they smell like basically these
things as well
do they make red vine candles uh no but
i feel
like i feel like you should have
something you should probably feel like
you could make any
any scent right probably this is good is
there red vine candles
god it's a nice smell damn that smells
really really good
chappelle hey [ __ ] chin offered me
cheetos earlier that's the first time i
ever offered you food huh yeah and what
did i say
no no thank you would you offer him
uh cheetos yeah i always ask from
sardines because nobody wants
sardines and jokoy had this like
badass like cookie that someone brought
him from this like really
eating it hold on he was eating it oh no
i did not eat that cookie hold on don't
kiss my ass
shut the [ __ ] up let me have my hey let
me have my let me help
you trying to fight me in the my man
wasn't all so so disciplined
that last night that last night
i knew he broke back
what was that thick leg
you ain't i forgot about this bro
i'm serious but fat shaming works though
like that that [ __ ] uh
that love island those boys are so
bodied i know
it's i mean i'm gonna get in shape as
well john how about on love island
season five you're in shape season five
halfway through they drop a super model
on these [ __ ]
really straight up rebecca i don't know
what her name is i
don't know anybody's name she came in
during the wand
surfer girl so funny no surfer girl's
lucy and she's the most fine one on
there
she's finer than a supermodel i think so
like a straight up
like good look like looks yeah dude
rebecca
i i don't know what her name is but she
is fine
that's always the one that pops up yeah
none of this the one on the left
nope the one that she probably is the
same one right but then you said that
they just got introduced to a new person
oh that's her in the very back she looks
like
[ __ ] there where this one that's her of
course she's a super oh we was clowning
her
super straight up super no we were
clowning her yes
oh how about your boy tommy fury you
know when they all sleep in the same
room
lights are off he's hit hooking up with
the chick
first one i've seen you look up there
which one hook it up with her molly
molly who's molly who's mom
uh molly's the blonde in that picture
she is she's
the this one uh no oh she's not in the
scripture which is weird
and she came later that's the original
cast
i think later but yeah she's she's dope
she's cool they're together right now he
hit me oh still
congratulations yeah but he's like
finger during the
show oh you gotta say that again he's
what he's
oh she's so pretty i mean there is his
finger he's also very pretty
he's he's by far the best-looking human
on the shoulder well that's that's
tyson's brother yeah
that's molly as well you had a look at
this guy from van uh the vanderpump
rules
yeah but better looking his eyes are
piercing blue
yeah he's he's gorgeous and it's like
every girl that comes on there's into
him but
they settle for the rest of the day i
can't remember if i
i if i asked this if you guys said does
he does he fight though oh yeah 4-0 pro
four no problem he's i think he's light
heavyweight oh [ __ ] yeah
what is that weight uh light is one
yeah 175 is that what you were fighting
at no i wasn't fighting i was playing at
147 at the time
147. yeah light light heavyweight
they're big boys
bigger oh bigger yeah oh who's that dude
you show me that's been knocking people
puerto rican dude
oh did you see the fights this weekend
shout out to shakira stevenson but this
uh
guy 16-0 16 first round knockouts
undefeated street uh he's out of what uh
brooklyn or something like that i forgot
his name uh to save you the time now
he yo he's the next boxing all right
like
30-0 but until they fight someone but
i'm saying this knockout street nobody
made it to the second round is that a
good thing that's a great issue
he's out of new york yeah he's i think i
know you're talking about oh wait kiss
my ass because i said ryan garcia
he's been on knockouts hasn't he no but
yeah nobody but he's talking about
fighting tank
that's the difference which is crazy i
doubt this guy's talking about fighting
no but the guy
listen they're matching him up with
people who've never been stopped before
and they're not making it to the second
round man i got to get this guy's credit
cause he fought
out yeah like everyone's tweeting about
him yes yeah that guy got joe and big
yeah everyone he's getting all the
rappers yeah he's not around
no i know but he was a big pun he said
yeah it was a fat joe big pun
um can you go to puerto rico he didn't
fight this weekend though yeah he did
fight this
he didn't yeah that's why the shakur
stevenson fight was so fast
fury look good i'm sorry joshua
his name is oh here it is
yes
b h is here god damn i know there
wait no hold on edgar edgar
ed oh edward edgar yeah and then you got
barlinga
berlinga yeah there you are this guy
shout out to him
porter yeah the new the new felix
trainer that
nate diaz oh yeah you said you look like
nike
on just that well just yeah i saw him
finding espn he's a monster
he's a beast that's what they call him
he fought again this weekend because he
just fought like a month ago he's
fighting starch guys yes
yeah and they can't get out the first
round like just
steamrolls through them like knocking
them out in and out
you know starch is like the shirts go
like that oh yeah yeah oh
yeah oh so he's knocking these
[ __ ] bro we yeah we
show me that one oh yeah so they can't
get out he's a big prospect for sure
yeah
and the guys he's not like knocking out
there's a lot of hype too
yeah so now the next guy listen people
go in thinking like i'm gonna make it to
the second round
they don't make it to the second round
that's how real his power is
damn 16-0 16 first round knockout so i
gotta give him credit man
and he's punching through the gloves
boxing's interesting because he's 16 or
16 knockouts
what happens when he gets in that eighth
and you know ninth round
when he can't knock the dude out you
know that's like the fight i saw he was
like trying to just destroy the dream he
did
yeah but what happens when that doesn't
work take it to the later rounds
yeah but it's it's there's gonna be
someone to figure it out oh yeah if they
give him the right match up he's gonna
get someone
he's not gonna beat him in the first
place andre ward can come out of
retirement and he can
starch andre ward with toy with him yeah
yeah oh really but yeah but he's not
that's why he's
he's young yeah he's a prospect yeah it
goes continue great prospect though
probably the biggest prospect we got
well is that how like tyson uh fury
figured out
wilder what do you mean like because
like wilder you know knocks people the
[ __ ] out too but
he was wild this guy has been boxing all
his life wilder is like more
oh god that's right 24. yeah never mind
okay
but joshua looked good yeah he did i
like him yeah fury he fought
he fought oh that's going down fury
wants it boxing's so [ __ ] up
yeah they just need to figure it out can
we show our way and talk about the fight
of the year and then we get off did you
watch it
i watched the burrito i mean you're
talking about brandon moreno the guy
of the year yes what did you think you
agreed for five years i had to draw too
you did oh yeah how does that work
though because uh
figarito won two rounds brandon moreno
won two rounds you got points and then
one round was point taken
and he won that round so be nine nine
nine nine okay yeah
okay so it's gonna have two two and then
a draw round
nine nine so it'd be a draw hey you're
going to close those nope
they're gonna go back they're doing so
well i'm checking out
[Laughter]
i can't believe there's no candles that
are scented with red don't find anything
oh you couldn't find anything
there's the guy who sends everyone
candles i feel like he's from uh
he's from uh colorado yeah he could
probably i'm a geek for candles a guy
said yes
i love candles a lot you know who else
said that
uh you don't nervous tony say the guy
who died
yeah yeah but i'm getting a thousand
candles dude
but uh candles aren't covered under
insurance if your house burns down from
a candle you're [ __ ] but i'm a candle
connoisseur
cool dude just know if that new crib you
got
burns down because you're burning
candles like a zappos guy look at that
energy he just threw at me i'm saying
though
i'm putting careful on you be very
careful oh
she catches on fire the home couch is on
fire
insurance is like nope it's
i don't have an opinion on it oh you
don't nope you wear lotion
no never you never wear lotion not even
on your knees never i'm not really
ashamed
not even on your knees stay hydrated i
know he biking
i mean yeah we stay hydrated too yeah
that's messed up that's kind of but
what what what are you saying
wait i don't know cat you stay lotion i
don't know why
why because they soft yeah but you're
soft because you're born soft though
no you have to maintain it no you
haven't my skin's soft as [ __ ]
i have soft skin i woke up like this
yeah but will you get like well your
hands get really ashy
yeah it'll be yeah it's just ashy but
it's not like chappelle's not really
ashy i feel like you're very much
malignant ash you're faster than
chevelle and that's not even like a diss
to you
but i don't even i don't even put on a
lot of lotion
whatever man this [ __ ] but for
these thighs i gotta
get a little shower i got lotion thighs
that's a rotisserie chicken i got a
[ __ ] dog we're not on the road
we're off three weeks if you count
because we went boise one show
three weeks basically we'll be right
back christmas next week
the whole week christmas week more
importantly we have malik and his
birthday and his diss track yeah
oh yeah yeah
next week what you guys doing for
christmas you know just at the crib
my son's catching on to santa being a
[ __ ] fake though
yeah he's catching he's starting to
catch on what gave it away because his
friend lives in an apartment
he was papa they because you know all
the movies we watch everything
santa's coming down the chimney
apartments don't have chimneys
so he goes how's he getting there and i
go he's
he they leave the door open
or they leave a window open he comes
through the window and he goes through
the window
my girl goes well that'd be a that'd be
a robber
i was like hey [ __ ] i know i know you
see me trying to try to
and then also you know it's just the
logistics of santa and sleigh with the
rangers on roofs like our roofs like
like
poor kids he's figuring it out poor kids
just mess everything that's good for him
let's get yeah [ __ ] elf on a shelf
shout out to all the parents with the
elf on the shelf it's exhausting
oh that's the current event oh she did
one oh yeah there it's a [ __ ] beast
dude
elf on the shelf yeah he's constantly
coming up with content for these [ __ ]
elves
and last night my son couldn't sleep
he's not allowed to be on youtube
and his uncle came over and was showing
him a bts video on youtube
but he [ __ ] up and did on his ipad my
son knows he can't be on youtube
so then when uh he he was like oh leave
that on there i'll listen to the music
he gets on there and goes to his videos
he went to a video where there's like a
zombie or something on there
and then 2 30 in the morning dad popeye
papa i go to the room like what dude and
i'm in my drawls
tired as [ __ ] yeah like what he's like
there's a zombie in here i'm like
there's no [ __ ] zombie he's like we
lay down with me like
[ __ ] i don't fit on his bed oh so i'm
on his bed my [ __ ] my
whole feet legs are hanging off yeah i
fall asleep my butt goes numb
[Laughter]
laughs
what did you do this weekend cat um i
didn't really do much i got my nails
done
um longer this time longer yeah nice and
long and then i got my pedicure done
but don't show anyone um and then for
only fans
except for only um but yeah i've been
watching love island i got so caught up
into it because
season uh i was still trying to do
season five i was just watching episodes
on youtube but they're like out of order
and they're not listed right so i got
hulu
yeah just kidding i try to get away with
watching it online
for free as long as i possibly can and
then also yeah do you the real deal holy
field
how about the new uh producer for uh
showtime in my show
works on the love island uh us she's the
producer for that show
i get all the download on it doug damn
so they get yeah so and especially they
film this new one they're in a
quarantine they're in a bubble dude
they're stuck in there so
two weeks of quarantine in a hotel then
they go 12 weeks in the house
and because they're in a bubble they
can't leave like on uk
they leave every saturday for like six
hours right yeah they get to go to the
beach they take their mics off they get
reset
in this quarantine one they're stuck in
that house see that would drive me
[ __ ]
i don't get why you do it i mean i guess
you need to love that but but that
but that would be even if they didn't
have the quarantine right if they have
the quality
for half for half the day they can go
off and do their own [ __ ] and come back
and like half a day well i don't get
like you know as an ultimate fighter
reality show we don't have our phones or
anything
and you're stuck in the house dude 12
weeks of that yeah they don't make much
money
uk though they're super famous they get
really famous yeah
america they don't get famous we have so
many different you name one [ __ ]
person out there
no off what the u.s one i have no clue i
don't even know there was a u.s
i love the new producer she's great i
don't [ __ ] with america we need an asian
one
that'd be cool right that'd be dope
y'all really [ __ ] with reality shows
yeah it was one time i was like with
yeah tyrese actually made one about
koreans
tyrese yeah it was like koreatown was it
about cars
no it's just about a group it's almost
like the real world he's in korea town
he's in koreatown and tyrese did it
tyrese
is he executive producer that sounds
awful no i think terrance um
howard is taran tower korean woman oh
terence howard is very yeah
yeah tyrese i don't think so yeah k-town
oh wow oh so it's a web series are they
famous
i don't think so answers no you don't
know yet
go go to uh k-town season one episode
one let me see episode one let me begin
this is in 2012 in july it's only on
youtube i think so
all right that's some 1.7 mil
1.7 mil oh [ __ ] i'm into it
all right hey what is
the date you mean 2012 july 2012
k-town it was so weird i tried watching
it but it was just
were you not feeling it nah because it's
like overacting i think
oh what a reality show but it's cool to
see this pl you know the spots
there's all the spots i like going to
how do you say bow bow
and i am an award-winning hairstylist
born and raised in
k-town 2-1-3 represent yeah it's your
very good
oh [ __ ] that thing has five thousand
likes
six thousand pesos
you never want that look trash
no [ __ ] like fire i need what
two weeks two weeks are they boxing okay
a little fight
hold on no the guy with the bandana he's
one of my friends
and she's pretty i was the first and
last guy to ever break my heart
oh i don't like this [ __ ]
i'm not killing it i'm not feeling it i
feel like brenda likes things people
generally don't like it's cool seeing
all this all these spots that
we all know but that's fake because yeah
you be hanging out in koreatown yeah i
didn't live far from it i lived in
western yeah yeah and then and then my
favorite hottie oh she's fine
uh chinatown how do you be honest oh
howlin right
is it yeah yeah it's it's owned by
asians
no it's owned by a white guy from i
think he's
somewhere from the south but uh it just
so happens the store front is in
chinatown
why are all these koreans in pasadena
what all their teeth are terrible
are they that one guy's teeth are social
this is how you know they just
just have really great that's what i'm
saying that's how you know the show is
fake no
no dennis asians really nothing worse
than an asian with bad teeth are you
serious just have grease
look at their [ __ ] teeth nothing
works birds are great my hands mine are
not
great teeth did you have braces oh i did
when i was a kid they borrowed
a terrible underbite bro they have good
teeth
generals asians do not have good time
teeth or is there's nothing worse
there's nothing
right yo is he right in japan i would
say
a lot of japanese i've seen him and they
have small
zoom in on that guy's teeth he only got
one well not his oh
his or her nightmare his oh those
okay that's just ridiculous this is
great i think that's also a little
different because
back in the day black teeth in asia were
popular that was like a
sign of being wrong a lot of candy or
something
no it's just almost like um the way you
would have like
i guess like grills and you have like
diamonds in your teeth that show that
you were wealthy
you had black teeth back in the day they
weren't even dead they were dyed
oh sick yeah bro but anyways
i haven't met uh i've never yeah i don't
think i've ever seen an asian would be
ain't hanging around enough asian i
think you're reaching i'll be i'll be
over there
over there
[Applause]
everywhere they're everywhere and but
there's a lot of issues in australia
but that's australia oh my god you can't
you got if we're talking about the root
of asians they they have great i don't
know
i don't think i've ever seen an asian
with bad teeth i know a dentist who's
bad and she's
asian and she left because she's the
instagram model now she's ooh
killing it yeah her name miss dana leak
you touch show me mrs dino
yeah daddy miss dana she got some she
got some nice pearly
she blew up right here she blew up i'm
saying before she was a god
absolutely you know her yeah listen what
the hell she's doing
she's going to be a dentist yes bro
she blew up teeth was crazy she always
wanted
you to do your beautiful
she's straight up asian bro she's all
that she looks like she's mixed
yeah she looks like she's part black
yeah she looks like she got black
she met me shoulda had it
i feel like she looks asian but she has
like not an asian baby
people think people like college the
chef chicken 580 000.
scroll down i think she got like a
throwback photo of her at the like the
dentist
uh what's she using do i well she's fine
look
look right right there yeah can you
imagine your dentist dressed like that
come on bro
i mean not dressed like that but wearing
the outfit like that dude i would get my
teeth cleaned
everything about the waist every week
she left and she became like she has a
career
i'll say it's us her laying down
look at that look at that look at that
look at that come on man
jesus moving on this picture is it
moving dude
i think that's real this is a tick tock
it's just tick-tock he's just saying
like yo i get uh
yeah it has to be real that's the thing
it really it could be real now that
asian girls are going to the gym
a lot of asian girls are having like
much more voluptuous bodies
oh okay but it also could be fake i
think it might be real because her
thighs kind of match
but just a she had a whole yeah like her
yeah her thighs yeah yeah she has thick
thighs
yeah she looks amazing yeah she's
pulling it on here but anyways that's
ass she's so pretty yeah but i'm saying
that what's the point dude
the point is asians i'm saying
they have great teeth and they like take
care of their like teeth in the mirror
yeah
yeah most of the yeah most of the
dentists i know are asian are asian
that's what i'm saying well she
shouldn't she should have stayed
dude unreal sorry yeah [ __ ] okay that's
enough man cause i'm i'm getting yeah
i get frustrated
the way bridges be looking at the screen
it has to be like some kind of symptom
like when you get
like stared at a beautiful girl for so
long you get upset only cars and girls
do that to me
oh yeah cars and girls what [ __ ] what's
the card that you're like man
you stared at it for so long there's a
bunch okay really i can just tell by
that deep breath
you want it you don't want to go down
i'm like that would uh i think
like that with band t-shirts
[Music]
compared to girls you
i'm like that with vintage
yeah like i'm like some grateful dead
old school
no see no it's not even that for me i
just love band t-shirts but like
i don't get ones that are like i search
for
like ones that are like more bootleg i
like the bootleg
yeah uh do you find them oh yeah i'm
they're tough to find though right
i'm good at it really yeah i've been
doing it forever oh damn tell me dog
i gotta find all these bootleg uh
there's yeah because i
i find these this is just dude i follow
uh dos bootleg on uh instagram
oh he's a shirt shirt guy oh yeah dude
he makes some of the dopest like
he made this uh dope ass la one hold on
have you done this
uh uh enneagram and yeah who's that in
that i got yeah so he makes a lot of
these girls
they're the la one those shorts one
yeah where's oh i see it damn those are
sick
yeah he's great dude yeah righty piper
on it uh-huh buddy rob piper
oh shout out yeah yeah he's he's a big
yeah he's a big la geek
but yeah dude i get a lot of stuff from
him any kobe oh there it is right there
what
yeah oh [ __ ] let me see i might have to
cop how much are they though
dude he's great pricing really 20 70
bucks yeah i'm around that oh there's a
website doug chappelle
i like this [ __ ] like that one yeah i
did yeah you did
you saw that yeah yeah you saw that it's
right there
yeah so that's where i got my doc
holidays
yes i'm gonna get some jobs okay i'm
about to give them dan davito yeah
that [ __ ] uh oh wow the the [ __ ]
uh
lost boys yeah dude he makes
so much extra free joe kelly that's dope
that's hard i'm telling you bro that's
my guy right keep going dude i've been
i've been going to this guy
uh using this guy since 60 dollars
that's not fair pricing
that's not bad cop three i i've been
using i've been using this guy
since like 2015 i think just 2014 or
2015 is when i i think
might be in 2014 i discovered him he's
24. yeah
look at like i'm telling he makes a
double check movie shirts
um he makes he makes so much dope [ __ ]
dope
those are really interesting like a lot
of boots a lot of dodger stuff
go past no watch yeah yeah go past the
dodgers i'm all set on dodger i'm not
mad at dodgers
no i love the dodgers but i'm just
saying go to like his
you gotta go to like his shirts and
stuff how do you find his shirts here
oh jogger's new best sellers
best sellers to see
that [ __ ] of course that's one of his
best sellers i went on the right
who's that that's a little lydia yeah
everyone's on little yoda's nuts oh i
got to get that
bloody yeah dude that shirt is [ __ ]
fire so that's when he was on break
taking smoking a cigarette oh an actor
yeah just taking a break
i mean oh they were on set i don't have
to get that yeah
that that doc holliday was like [ __ ]
chainsaw
chainsaws
yeah okay okay yeah i wonder how you can
do all this without licensing
cliff burton i don't know yeah cliff
burton from metallica
r.i.p all right the lost boy ones i love
that
so that prince one scroll down i got
that prince one too
all right all right i'm a little gay
you see that stone cold one yeah these
guys
well that joker one's great that's joker
when he's doing the tv commercial jack
nicholas yeah
yeah dog i'm about to light this wait he
got omar i mean
yes yeah omar tell me russell
yeah that's what you want for your
birthday yeah i want the uh more little
shirt
24. i'm cheap you know you want that you
want that that's not
george
hey two people complimenting me on how
they're full of [ __ ]
what'd they say it was like yo i heard
you see i'm fighting the kids i see your
legs it's bigger in person
it's better i also been i've also been
doing two days uh a week at leg day so
yes all these leg jokes about to be
deceased malik's looking a little thick
these days i'm gonna think i got a shirt
on i'm
not okay you going for it
big boy's a spirit more than anything
you know you don't have to be an actual
thick boy
yeah no sticks in here in your arteries
clog the arteries what's in your heart
man
2014 or something i short some new
grateful dead uh tortillas from uh
junk food you ever junk
junk food okay their [ __ ] always sells
out drives me [ __ ] nuts but i gotta
email this morning
[ __ ] yeah junk food's dope oh they're
expensive though huh
uh a little more than your boys yeah
so yeah i don't find stuff like that i
go like scroll down chin some of their
grateful dead shit's dope
the mtv won't like keep scrolling down
not that one
that one's all right that one's sold out
already damn
what's great for i got a fire grateful
dead one see the far right one
yes he does yeah the europe yeah choice
i'm getting my hair like that
let me see oh that'd be dope right get
it dreaded up and stuff
you look like the michael b jordan
killmonger hair yeah
oh you look like uh homeboy dave
chappelle on uh know your professor
he was like i heard a dreadlock he's all
[ __ ]
it's the same here
it's dave chappelle let's see yeah they
do show us there
there it is i can't take this
no i can't take this should i get him
should i get him now it's time for
reggie let's talk about
your mama don't hurt me not rich
such a who should i get him who's
sucking who's titty
now just imagine how talented you were
the book rolls like that with teeth like
that
that's like it just speaks monster yeah
monster
damn women be shocked women be shy
you got to give eddie murphy [ __ ]
credit for when
uh that part where he's getting where
he's uh
sure fat part yeah um when he's getting
roasted
and his face of his defeat oh yeah the
acting
there is so [ __ ] great he's a great
actor yeah
great i mean you're acting like you're
breaking news i'm saying but
if you watch that no i'm not saying that
but at that specific part
of that movie yeah he's great show that
kind of sadness that yeah yeah
it's so funny you did it hold on wait is
there you going
are you showing producers you're acting
right
man yeah like you're breaking new it's
great
i just love that the holiday season is
here and nothing says i love you like
some meat on your grill i'm talking
about omaha steaks
right now you can get mouth-watering
steakhouse caliber package
an exclusive price just for you guys
it's called the deluxe griller's
assortment just saying the name makes me
super hungry for 129 129.99 to be exact
you'll get four tender butchers cut
flaming youngs
eight boneless chicken breasts all right
four ultra juicy omaha steak burgers
jumbo franks we got freaking wrap scout
potatoes
caramel apple tartlets what are we doing
here man
this package also includes a free
digital meat thermometer
and four free omaha steak burgers go to
omahasteaks.com enter
the code fighter into the search bar and
order this package today
plus you get a free burgers and digital
meat thermometer
all right this holiday stay home send
great gifts
and eat great with the best steak of
your life guaranteed go to
omahasteaks.com type in fighter in the
search bar
order today that's omahasteaks.com
keyword fighter
listen some of you don't know what to do
for stock and stuffers how about you
give your hairy dad your hair
grandma the best stock and suffer ever
i'm talking about manscape
manscape is the ultimate stalker stuffer
this holiday season
all right they have the tools to make
sure you look your best
and you're hairless all right they also
release their products across europe
canada straight up we worldwide baby uh
they got the crop preserver
ball deodorant their crop reviver ball
toner
they got the body wash crop mop ball
wipes foot duster for your stinky feet
all right
they got the weed whacker nose and ear
trimmer and let's not forget my favorite
the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
doesn't nick your balls or your butt
when you're shaving all right
um get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code
fighter 20 whether this is for your
partner your dad your brother
your friend get them something that they
will actually use
and it's almost sure to get a laugh get
20 off and free shipping at manscape.com
with the code fighter 20 be the
ballsiest gift giver this year with
manscaped again that's manscape.com
promo code fighter 20.
i just love that before brendan this is
for you i'm sure you know more about
this than i do but
after 51 years the zodiac killers uh
little coded message was broken by three
people and they're three
random people not like why right uh
they're private citizens one was
a software engineer another one is a
computer program
not by like government officials yeah
not my government regular like citizens
and they've been one of them have been
deciphered trying to decipher this
message
since 2006. peep this so the zodiac
killers
never been caught he was a serial killer
in
northern cali he'd kill couples they did
a movie on it zodiac killer
jake gyllenhaal uh yeah it was great
great movie
they've never caught him ever he's an
old man now if he's still out there he's
an old man now
they never caught him he was so gangster
he would kill people
and then he would terrorize the city and
send these notes that they deciphered
they'd say he'd send notes
to the big outlets like the san
francisco chronicle
he sent it to the news stations he sent
[ __ ] to the police department
they could never figure out who's doing
it damn so these people just crack
and they all figure it they all had the
same uh i mean they
all they all worked together so they
worked as an old guy
have you seen the documentary don't [ __ ]
with cats you know like the facebook
group found them yeah it's kind of like
this
yeah but they didn't find them they just
broke down his
note from four so they don't even know
what the guy looks like they know that
that's
crazy though like stevie has his note
hung over the
bathroom so every time he pees he looks
at it and tries to figure it out stevie
does
yeah stevie but uh the fbi came out
after
looking over it for two weeks after it
was submitted they
concluded that this is probably gonna be
what the actual message is like no one's
gotten this close
to being as accurate as they were did
they release the message they did
release the message
was it wasn't it's pretty creepy but
also you know how the the how they're
like
the government uh the fbi uh nor cal
the the police department's like you
know it's an ongoing investigation
we're still gonna find justice for the
victims you ain't doing [ __ ]
nobody nobody's looking into that that
was like 40 years ago
yeah it was tough it was in the 70s
this is what it said i hope you're
having lots of fun trying to catch me
that wasn't me on the tv show which
brings up a
point about me i'm not afraid of the gas
champ because it will send me to
paradise all the sooner
because i now have enough slaves to work
for me where everyone else has nothing
when they reach paradise so they are
afraid of death clearly a psychopath
i'm not afraid because i know that my
new life will be an easy one in paradise
you spell paradise wrong because yeah
that's the one bit that people are still
trying to figure
out because a spell paradise with the c
instead of a s
and so they think that stands for
something but they don't know what that
stands for
a pair of dice paradise because life is
a gamble
oh i'm not afraid because i know that my
new lifestyle does that mean he's in las
vegas
oh you know what was in las vegas
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] oj was popping in the 70s
he rushed for 2
000 yards from buffalo bills and then he
was the zodiac killer
don't put that on hello twitter i was on
the road
but no don't put that i thought we were
figuring this no no
it's like the first 48. what kind of
code it was
love it yeah yeah the very killer's so
interesting never caught him
some great books on him too oh my god
wait do they think that's him or
something
no they have no idea who the [ __ ] is
that guy presents most evidence that the
deceased's dad was the zodiac
so that's the death if he is alive he's
like 90 years old
oh yeah like you know the golden state
killer different guy
uh yeah they caught him like way later
right dude
way later old man got life in prison and
actually
the comedian uh what's his name plays
ratatouille
small guy that nozzle patton oswald's
ex-wife who passed away
caught him oh yeah
and then there's a documentary on hbo
about it the golden state killer
so he would just break into people's
homes rape them and then
uh would kill some of them and just rape
the others
and he was a police officer
but this in the 70s when people have
like alarms and [ __ ]
like what are we in the 70s what the
[ __ ] you doing dude even
leaving the windows opening what the
[ __ ] yeah where are you guys
i thought santa claus was coming they
made it too easy for them yeah they
thought
okay yeah yep they made it too easy for
these cereals yes
but you know you know what i know the
world's on fire right now we think the
world's coming to the end
you know the world's especially in
america way safer today than it was in
the 70s and 80s and 90s
way safer we have technology we have a
citizen's app
yeah but also but also just safer people
aren't killing people as much anymore
yeah [ __ ] that citizens out why you said
why do you say that
zen zach will stress you out yeah yeah
if you have the ring app it's like
current like [ __ ] you read it like jesus
christ
yeah bunch of snitches yeah oh dude and
then anxiety oh you don't want uh
i i got off of it there's a mountain
lion on the loose around my house so i
was all [ __ ] scared yeah this was in
the neighborhood
did you ever see them online never oh so
and then i
and then i thought i heard the mountain
lion every night at three in the morning
so now you paired up my gun right i was
just [ __ ] had my
ar-15 out i was in my undies waiting to
snipe him out
you know what it was what it was my pool
cleaner would come out though because it
climbs the walls
it'd come out of the water and go
you're like tiger in the zombies yeah
right here he's taking out there with my
airfield
i'm like yo [ __ ] mountain light i was
texting joe
rogan i was like you want mountain lion
meat [ __ ] you're getting cocky
yeah you want to sign up don't worry and
then yeah don't worry
i was like don't worry fam
who wants real mountain lion and i put
my address come on hold for grill
mountains
this meat is on me yeah this meat's on
me
you care if i put my meat on your grill
but then
the pool cleaner came out was all
you got mad as well we have to tone it
down
the suction was too great people eat
mountain lions yeah they said it's
really delicious which is weird it's cat
it's disgusting oh my god
it's disgusting mountain lion
tenderloins they look good
i would never it's like pork looking
yeah it does look like i legit thought i
was gonna kill mountain lion no that's
so funny i know he was talking [ __ ] of
that about that citizen after he was
like man y'all a bunch of [ __ ] i got
it [ __ ]
you important y'all bring the sauce
hashtag heat up grill right now hashtag
protector
hashtag quinlan hills protection
he got upset i could just see him cog oh
dude i swear all my life in the morning
just
you got the b money yeah i do it's ready
and
that article was submitted by max knight
on instagram
this one is from jermaine bakersfield
kim kardashian got so tired
of doing elf on the shelf every single
night that she came up with a plan put
them in mason jars
and wrote a note to her kids saying that
they had to be on a 10-day quarantine
brilliant damn that's why i might say yo
the elf's caught the sickness
during the quarantine it's smart
although
this next week's christmas so you let
him out for christmas
kim's so smart
[Music]
it's so smart it's exhausting
is kaye playing the piano no they're
actually living in separate houses
they're not getting along
really yeah oh wow okay brandon yeah
they turned a happy video set wait i
want to know
who's playing the [ __ ] piano in the
back like a psychopath
the other thing is uh i forgot elf on
the shelf one night my son we would
every more wake up he's like dad where's
the else we look i forgot to
put him up i was like oh dude you were
bad yesterday
you asked he wasn't bad i think you
remember we talked back to
papa in the hot tub he's all yeah i'm
like the house heard that
and so they're not moving tonight he
loves the hot tub huh
every night dawg that was funny
okay so bruce buffer is on cameo and he
did a cameo for a girl
where he broke up with her boyfriend for
her oh
this is hilarious okay
hold on this is so hilarious no it's
only good if the girl
knows time
for kaylee to
move wait what
she's all what the [ __ ]
i think haley's the one breaking up with
the guy
oh that's and he's probably a big ufc
fan yeah that's sad isn't it that would
make more sense
yeah i thought it was the boy what a way
to break down what's up girl
he's all what the [ __ ] he's all bruce
buffer [ __ ] yeah she's all just watch
keep watching though that's hilarious
wow okay so the cleveland baseball team
is going to drop
the word indians from their team name
everyone's following suit with
washington football too yeah everyone
will be called cleveland
yeah basically yeah well listen i got a
cleveland indians jersey with the indian
on it and i'm never
gonna stop wearing it ever
you do you point take it i love that
indian
check it out when i was a kid creative i
used to wear a cleveland indian's hat
the pro back and i took a gold sharpie
to put his uh one tooth goal
oh we used to wear to school there you
go gangster
cubs hat and i took a white sharpie and
put uh paul prince all over the bill
you did oh you're always making merch oh
he's always making mercy he's always
this look at you he can draw
yep you can't yeah yeah you could draw
people you could actually draw pretty
good
that's what's up damn all right so you
design oh okay yeah what's up doctor
well as long as they don't say cleveland
baseball team because washington
football team they killing right now
number one in the division well it's the
shittiest division on the planet
well we just fall at five and seven
they're number one in their division
yeah but
yeah they won they won they had to they
said they were awful
awful redskins awful even though i cheer
for alex smith
yeah but they they they're six and seven
right now they won yesterday yeah
terrible
they need their ass done either way
their ass
eighteen up in the [ __ ] planet they
did they they're on a winning streak
right now that defense isn't chase young
yeah healthy yes obviously he's the
rookie of the year
if you want to be if you really want to
look at it no no cuz because a lot of
people was on um
your boy the quarterback but yeah the
team's too bad right
exactly and this guy is putting up
numbers chase young
yes from ohio he's a freak oh what does
that mean putting up numbers
like he's his stat like yeah he's just
he's a he's he's a
big contrib uh contributor to the
defense he's a super beast
but anyways uh the washington football
team my [ __ ] buffs lost on saturday
we're undefeated
ranked top 20 and they [ __ ] lost to
utah
oh and you see our best players jerry
rice's son
yes oh they had a punt return and then
caught a touchdown too
he's a beast they told me to sing you do
they have a video of that yeah hold on
they told me
i don't know did they say show brendan
this hold on the punt return
yeah his name is also brendan but spelt
with an e
which they misspelled at starbucks all
the time
jerry's son brendan rice also he's
number two i think dude
rock 80 brendan rock [ __ ] 80 bro
you got the video yeah i'm seeing did he
see him forehead like his daddy
yeah say foreign that's not him
or maybe it is jerry rice jr
no no no there's a guy in college hold
on
uh chen i'm sending it to you through
instagram all right yeah commission
colorado ballin
here it is right here
i just sent it to you okay look at this
real quick had two big plays
this weekend against colorado utah
and this comes uh from my guy uh
i ain't got a weird instagram name so
i'm not jc
uh lincoln jc shaz
yeah did you send it to me yeah just
them to you i dm'd you
dm'd me yeah so you pull it up so you
can pull it up on that
i mean that's easier if you just put it
up in your um on the laptop
when you try to see chen's dms put his
dms out there like that
right i didn't i didn't think about that
i apologize you're right
i didn't even people get mad that he
don't reply back to them and [ __ ] what
[ __ ] what i mean
some people gotta understand i mean it's
busy you just moved into a house
look at this look at this hold up i
don't like how they do the audio thing
now
look at this poem return
no the snow is [ __ ] what's the move
oh my god stop playing with him i wait
get out of here
get out of here you weak kicker hey he
got him he got another oh
you got another one hold on he got
another one he has a he had two you know
that's the next slide yes sir watch this
stop playing with him bro stop playing
with him
stop playing with him
[Music]
please look at this now he won't look at
it because his team lost
cool yeah so shout out to jerry rice son
but uh
what's his name this son uh brendan rice
or something like that oh yeah brandon
yeah that was good uh great weekend for
them
killing it she weakened from the buffs
though
how about oh my god you remember i think
kat brought this uh
current event last week we didn't do it
no we were talking about this i sent it
to you last week
everyone keeps tagging me and they're
saying that's me really
yeah wait so we didn't use this for
carving no no i sent you last week so
bring it by monday
this is insane yeah he's pretty he's uh
uh looking at charges now yeah child
abuse charges
have you seen this no so it was a pee
wee football coach pretty [ __ ] don't
watch
his addre his things too i want to see
it yeah show the real video
okay let me see dude if that was my kid
look what he does to him boom
oh my god
he punched him in the head and he didn't
punch him he like slapped it
and then he hits him again wait no no no
he'll go back yeah he does oh my god
so look there's the it's him again there
oh he knocked him down
yep and then the kid gets up right no
other adult
said [ __ ] isn't that crazy bruh
he would have been stomped the [ __ ] out
dude if that's if that's my son yeah
oh dude you're not wait so was that his
kid or was it a random kid on the team
wait we got to watch the the
interrogation thing because not the
interrogation but his apology because
listen to what he says
this is the probably one of the more
disturbing parts of this he said i
should have done it
behind closed doors so is it his son
what took now but at the end of the day
i am a man they're not gonna make no
excuses for what i did
i was wrong i shouldn't disciple him
what so this this wouldn't be the first
time he's done this
oh it's not the first time no
[Music]
he can't even look at the camera well he
lost his job and now he's facing charges
dog if you touch it
yeah that's what they said the family
forgave him that's what he was saying
which is crazy and this is probably he
can still get charges though he's going
to be charged
charged with challenges he should never
coach again this is and this is pop
warner correct
yes where was this
uh florida florida okay so that big
that's big a football town
huge football so yeah okay yeah that's
serious right now serious
that's dope but also to the family out
there you gotta understand
and uh florida is like a big like
football state like they
breathe pop-up honors so there's an area
there i think
it's not day count it might be clark
county clark county the most
nfl players out of any county come out
yes because they all started at that
young age
like antonio brown came from there like
they all start that young
yeah like did you who was telling me the
story that they was like you saw 11
like like eight-year-olds like bodied up
walking around with like with
like a football player yeah but they
breed football players so when he
slapped them
and he's saying like kids they probably
see that all the time but i've never
seen
i don't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
okay that was my trying to make an
excuse
i would have came out like [ __ ] stone
cold steve you came
out of the top rope and beat the [ __ ]
out in front of all the kids
yeah no like if you can't get your point
across without [ __ ] just
speaking words no yeah you gotta hit oh
the bigger the bigger issue is the
family not having an issue with it
yeah because if you condone that what's
that kid's life like at home
if the mom and dad are like oh we don't
have a problem with like what
yeah well i think the it i didn't see
anything about the dad's situation so
i'm just gonna say the mom is like
taking her to the him to the games and
stuff like that
but if he had a dad around i guarantee
that coach would i gotta give him
coaches now they can't do what they used
to like i remember i could just grab our
face man we [ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah
shaker yeah just the old
my basketball coach usually hit me in
the back of my head with the clipboard i
dare my cheer coach to ever [ __ ] grab
not hard but just like
no he's grabbing my cheer coach grab me
bro they're getting kicked in the phone
i'm like chill coach i got 30.
yep yeah 30.
that's a lot of points dog i remember
shout out to prairie middle school we
were playing uh this kid his name was
jason williams he went on to play
division one
he had 40 points in the first half what
like
we're gonna take brendan we're gonna put
you on him for the second half he
dropped 60 on me
was it white chocolate that boy had a
hundred points no he's a black dude are
you seriously williams
he had a hundred points dude he's
pulling up from half court on me
just [ __ ] this is whacking this is
before steph curry oh dude
beast legend scored 60 on me
what he scored we're gonna put you
scored 40 on my boy
yeah what what did the coast think that
we had no we had nothing
why isn't it double throw the ball out
of this we tried it didn't matter he was
that much better than all of this yeah
we're a bunch of white kids he played
for a [ __ ] we try to give you a
chance though
100 i blame the coaching you about your
name the coaching the coach is what
you're the one running the zone [ __ ]
that is true you run the zone he had
four four
yeah you stay in the zone yeah you gotta
put what did your four chord press
try it damn damn undeniable
and then you say division one he went on
division one yeah
yeah that's what you found out like when
you like really good okay
yeah what else you got do
you guys or did you guys hear about that
guy keonta johnson
i saw him training on twitter who is he
yeah he said he passed out during the
middle of the game he was blind
he's also like the preseason player of
the year and
he suddenly after a time timeout he came
back in and collapsed on court and now
he's in a
critical but stable condition he did
have coveted before so they're wondering
if it's related
but let me know no i was going to say
my first thought was not kobe my first
thought was enlarged heart
yeah my first thought was nothing to do
with code
and then they're going to blame covet
well you got it like did you did you see
debo passed away
yeah he had kobe got was fine from it
and then he passed away
like yeah he did have cove and it's like
doug
well my first start was sixth sense with
martin lawrence i mean martin
marlon wayne's uh but the guy the guy
when he passed out it was at the timeout
he was already balling
and i want to also understand what they
seem by stable but in critical
condition what does that mean like i
don't understand that it's so it's not
getting
they got it under yeah it's not getting
worse it's like he's he's not getting
worse
he's gonna get better it's okay so but
so serious [ __ ] it's serious so you
critical
who knows how much better he's going to
be also they're saying that's because of
covid no they're saying that
they're he's they're saying that he did
have coveted before so it's going to be
something that they're going to take
into consideration
is it part of it is something yeah
there's something about the covid
causing this to happen did i have a
video of him passing out i don't think
so his videos
on twitter it was on twitter i don't
want to see that man pass out i know
i kind of don't want to see it either
i'm trying to see what just him pass out
but you'll watch
dudes get knocked out uncontrollably
yeah but i think that's different like
that's like it could be a heart like
every it was a
yeah my first thought was enlarged heart
because it happened
yeah because it happens a lot of
athletes my first thought about
dehydration
oh [ __ ] face first wait let me see just
like that leg gave up
oh my gosh that's terrible yeah
i wonder what happened yeah they don't
they don't have anything what's going on
but they put him in a medically induced
coma that's the most recently
they go on to win the game no they
listen they'll think about boycotting
that game
why because because like they didn't
want to play after that why not
what do you mean but he was shocking
yeah he was a boy
he was a prospect no i get it bro you
gotta care but
you don't quit the game but his homies
like what the bro if you see your homie
yeah
one of your best friend friends best
friend he's gonna die you don't know
your emotions yeah you don't want to do
anything
listen i understand but they
what do you mean it was a long pause
though don't get me wrong
it was a long people were of course they
stopped the game after
[ __ ] homie on dallas
oh yeah no that's that's prescott yeah
literally
they do that all the time they do it all
the time but they carry on the game you
know what i'm saying like
we know this season's over they carry on
the game but if you don't i'm pretty
they cared about them and basketball are
close because there's only 15 guys you
travel around
and you're on a plane and he was balling
that's your homeboy and you just see
like imagine we doing a podcast and i
fall face front
are you going to continue the podcast
i'd be like damn we need to get to the
hospital and we'd come back and finish
the podcast yeah like what's up malik
wait hold on hold on
that's all right hey can i get my rules
i'll give him the update
put a few red ones in his pocket wave
red rise in front of him i'd be stalking
again like okay
can you imagine a sport stopped every
time a guy
had an injury or whatever that's what
i'm saying like kevin durant went
towards achilles or
when steph curry [ __ ] up his so what
makes that that different than that is
because i
i get like i'm trying to follow you i'm
not yeah saying
yeah you're crazy for what you're
thinking i'm trying to uh okay
college guys right yeah during covet
didn't have to have a pre-season
like that right so you're already bonded
with each other you're you're in the
same hotel
but in the bubble the guy is balling
that [ __ ] that's your team like he's a
pro
he's a draft pick balling and your star
player
out of the timeout all right cool you go
here you go here and we're walking and
you see that he passes out
there was a such a long even the other
the other side of the
people on the team it was like yo if you
want to cancel we understand we could
just
you know cancel and fourth that would be
insane if they canceled off that
i think because as a former athlete
and i you can reschedule them like your
mind is how can you go back balling with
your homework
how are they supposed to go out back
balling after dak prescott he cut his he
hurt his leg this guy could have gotta
be
you to be professional man you got to
carry on all right
i think i i i i'm not saying you're
crazy for what you think i'm just trying
to understand like
because i know i mean i didn't [ __ ]
play those kind of sports i just cheered
them on you know yeah we sat down on our
channel
you're all right we love you damien
i've never forget what it is carry on
doug there's the free throw line up
cheerleaders
i can't believe you did that i can't
believe you did that
i have the girl i have my hand around
her back my hand be like this
and we just wait come on you got this
you can get out
so y'all all in the knee and he walk off
the court
and go back to the girl up in the air
this is home field position
why everybody else is like oh stay back
stay back yeah
yo but um no i get what you're saying
who is that oh yeah so far what does she
have
um how about this one
obama bush george w bush and uh
i think bill clinton or hillary clinton
yeah people aren't trusting the
vaccination because uh biden came out
was like oh
uh because black people mexicans are
affected by it they're like
uh the vaccine should go to low-income
black families and mexicans first
yeah and the black culture like
charlemagne talks about us all the time
he's like we ain't taking it first [ __ ]
that
y'all have never helped us then now you
want to give us
the first vaccinations he's like get the
[ __ ] out
of here so bill clinton and george bush
voluntarily
like yeah and obama they're gonna get it
on air wait so
here's the thing people are already
taking it yeah yeah yeah how do we know
it's the same
that's the that well that's
charlemagne's thing he's like how do i
know what you're taking is what
we're all gonna get because they're
presidents so they have another one
you want to hear a conspiracy theory i
know you love that yeah okay
i don't love them but what did you get
malik news report again
is the news reporter no yeah we did no
no no
i kept this to myself okay okay because
i want to freak her out
so you know how we had a second wave of
covet
they were saying they were putting the
uh covey like how you get in the nasal
nasal and it's cl it's close to your
brain you [ __ ] exhaust me i swear to
god
right when you're wrong
okay so that's how they knew a second
wave was coming because they want a
second wave to come
to make sure the validate the lockdowns
correct now did you hear
new sims being recalled not in here
recalled means they're based trying to
get him out of
office it happened once before in
california when arnold schwarzenegger
became governor that's how he became
governor
yeah so newsome's done such a shitty job
people hate him so much
they're trying to recall him and so
serious he hired a team to help him out
with this
so recall means they're going to take a
vote they're going to get another
republican to run against them
and that republican can win now i think
he's going to get recalled but i don't
think
that the public is going to come in yeah
but just him the fact he's getting
recalled let you know that people
[ __ ] hate him hate him which is a
great thing
yeah he's a piece of [ __ ] i i mean i you
know a lot of my
you know people back home been you know
asking me about like how you know how's
it going yeah you know how's it going
out there like you're okay
i go yeah i'm fine but i was like what's
sad is like you watch
you you literally watch these uh
business people with these businesses
and these restaurants and like
you know their backs are against the
walls and they're supposed to just like
stop but they don't you know there's no
help you know to get there's not there's
no help but then you know there's
nothing
my thing is there's no rhyme or reason
either it's like how did block
downs go in march better so sad
oh yeah i mean uh what's his name uh
dave portnoy portnoy
yeah yeah great guy yeah i saw i saw
this video and what do you say
he's basically saying what i'm yeah what
i'm spinning but you can see what i love
it's a little bit more in depth okay
i've done that a bunch i can't believe
it i have to do it again but new york
city just closed
indoor dining my hair is [ __ ] big
new york is he from new york yes boston
well boston but he
he lives in new york it might be least
out of there barstool is out of here
they're done the bar and restaurant
industry and small business
have been squeezed and squeezed and
squeezed
and they've tried everything they've
been as creative as possible
you get the outdoor dying these
structures they have to build on their
own dime you have the glass in between
the masks
you've had the six feet of separation
fewer tables they've been as creative as
you can be
to save their livelihoods to save what
they've spent
decades of blood swear sweat and tears
building
they've done whatever they scratch and
clawed and now a few politicians
in new york city's like and you're done
we're shut it down no indoor that how do
you expect these people to survive
yeah but also there's no evidence that
the indoor dining spreads covet
there's why can i go to target i won't
say who it is my one of my
closest people in my life worked for the
kova team
in la all the data and was on a zoom
call
with the head the [ __ ] lady who looks
like death you know the [ __ ] [ __ ] we
always say on tv
can he he goes you're going to shut down
indoor dining and you go yep and he goes
what evidence do we have that that
sweats code they go none
because you have no evidence he goes no
no evidence yeah it's just optics
yeah wow how it's optics and people are
losing their [ __ ] businesses and
their income to provide for their family
over what optics to show that those
the horrible [ __ ] we've been through
yeah just to make sure you're not so
upset that
you know they're doing it for a reason
exactly well and like like dave porter
said people are
being as creative as they can you know
what i mean like they're doing
give us the details give us what you
know and then let americans decide
what is the best thing possible yeah
like like if you're hanging around your
grandma all the time
if you're with your old people at the
time don't don't go don't be on tour
don't don't come to a show of mine don't
go to restaurants
you be safe if you're not though you
give americans
the info you let americans decide what
they want to see democracy
listen if people want to come to comedy
shows they have that right
people want to go eat outside they have
that right
but when you dictate nope you can't do
that well now we're talking about north
korea
now you're talking about russia [ __ ] you
give us the information
you let americans decide what they're
willing to risk and what they're not
that's how americans ran and that's why
people are upset
i know it's and now if if you can prove
to us that wearing a mask
is the best thing to do how many people
are masked now
everyone's in i can't believe in it yeah
no but you wear because you have to info
that mass help
yes which that there's debate to that
either way that you
that on planes we wear masks you give us
the info we got it cool i'm going to
wear a mask
i don't want to put the other people in
danger correct but for them to say no
you can't make a living
is insane it's the most on american
thing that's
ever been done that is the most on
american thing that's ever been done in
our lifetime
ever and just that you know
here's the funny thing about it in march
we did the research we shut down
what happened all right but this is the
thing the cdc
and the world healthcare right now the
cdc and world health organization said
said lockdowns aren't for that long
period of time the humans aren't made to
be locked out you can't do that
it has to be a short amount of time you
[ __ ] went overboard with it
yeah and then what's newsome doing he's
going to restaurants yeah he's doing
what's pelosi doing she's going to
restaurants what's what's what's his
kids doing they're going to school yeah
now i guaran [ __ ] to you if you went
dude you got to stay in your house
you got to take a hit to your salary and
your kids can't go to school you got to
school train them
guarantee everything would be open but
they don't live like us
so why you would listen to a politician
is beyond me
why would you listen to someone living
in a [ __ ] on top of the mountain why
would you let them make decisions
for everybody living underneath i know
why would you listen to those people
is insane to me it's just like we're
shouting at the mountaintops
it's cheap it's sheep listen to the
commander it's insane to me we still put
up with it
and he's being recalled for this exact
[ __ ] reason yeah
and then you look at new york to do you
look in new york uh
now one of the reasons we went to severe
lockdown
obviously control hospitals agree with
that hospitals weren't overrun they're
not
hospitals in the winter because of flu
and other because
diseases do spread in the cold hospitals
get busy during
during the winters they're no busier
than any time of the year now
you go back and look the hospitals are
not busy or because of kovac right now
they're not they're just not
hospitals always busy during the winter
but you go back to uh
uh what's the number cuomo the reason
all this happens because he went oh
old people you're sick well unless
you're severely sick go back to the old
folks home
the number one thing that [ __ ] killed
all those old people oh
and that [ __ ] won an award an
emmy for the way he dealt with it
now he has sexual uh assault accusations
against he does
yes these [ __ ] dude you're
talking about the scum of the earth
telling you what to do
and you're listening and you're
listening to them
you're talking about people that don't
live like we do making decisions on the
way you live
even though they're living a different
life yeah it doesn't affect them
so they can shut down the restaurants
because it doesn't affect them they're
still getting their salary from the
government
so their kids are still in school
they're on vacations they're in their
penthouses
and you're listening to them yeah they
don't feel the same effects that we
feel nope no but i guarantee you if you
if
you put them in the way of their rights
they're i'm telling you they're going to
be different
they're school pelosi pelosi yeah
getting her haircut
not wearing a mask going to restaurants
yeah
it's so crazy to me that we listen to
these people on their on their high
horse
it's nuts ugh i agree i'm just so
and even fountain went we can't we can't
do we can't keep doing this man
people they're not buying into the
government fouchy the safest most
cautious guy in the world is like we
can't keep doing this man
because we're losing trust in the
government look at the approval ratings
everybody
look at the brew of everybody people
[ __ ] hate government officials yeah
it's just they're they're [ __ ]
politicians enough to wear that question
like what how do i know
i'm getting the same batch as you like
people are starting to question there's
all this [ __ ] well there's the problem
that's what i'm saying that's
a vaccination listen it affected my
family negatively
i don't think vaccines are all bad it
just affected my son bad
i don't think we should go away the
vaccinations but now because of
what uh newsome did and uh fouchy
and uh [ __ ] pull up pelosi and cuomo
did
now people don't want the vacation
because they don't believe what the word
they're saying yeah when vaccinations
are
only for us and the only way when you're
back to normal is through the
vaccination
but now because you guys [ __ ] it up so
bad now people are questioning that
no in all this you know what this sounds
like it sounds like mental gymnastics
and we keep going and back flipping on
you you said it right
i know you appreciate that yeah did he
ever say it wrong he said gymnastics
yeah gymnastics
he knew what he meant though well you
know i was portraying
that's not a word what do you see what
do you say this [ __ ] better be stupid
[Laughter]
and when he says that i just go with him
what did you say what did you say
that should be strupa mental
that's a lot of stupid going on yo yo
stupid
dave portnoy actually ended up donating
five hundred thousand dollars to a
relief fund for
uh people who work in the restaurant
industry awesome don't talk about it be
about it i like that yeah
yeah i think you're true all right yeah
[ __ ] all that noise
i wish uh yeah i wish there was a way
that i could like
buy a family their uh christmas presents
because people were so [ __ ] by cobin
yeah but it's like i don't want to just
donate it because can you do it for
a toy drive like those go to family yeah
but
i'd rather just like a fan like hey we
don't have any money in my disney
presents
i buy them gifts yeah i don't know yeah
we should set something up is there a
way to do that
i don't want to go through a government
thing i don't trust them
i don't go through some big organization
i want some family to email
uh the final kid shop at gmail.com okay
we have no money might i have
four kids and i'll buy you gifts i'll
put up but
the problem is the problem is is like
obviously people take advantage of that
we don't know if it's a real family i
don't know how you do it
send me all your pictures if i am i need
a baby
if i'm gonna give my hard earned money
to you i need to see like profile pics
and all that i want to see you
struggling
so yeah joshua joshua used to have a
thing for these kids they were
uh there's like kids that didn't have
families and stuff and i'd donate
all this [ __ ] but i'd go with josh and
drop it off so i knew it was getting to
that
exact family yeah so yeah i'm sure
there's a way yeah
[Music]
what else you got uh this one right here
sam smith
and shawn mendes sean did sean mendez
had to apologize for misgendering sam
smith
did you guys know that sam smith the
singer who's gay
i love his voice when he came out i was
like oh my god
this is finally something he came out of
the closet no no wait when he
when he first came out like on the radio
yeah yo brandon you god damn it
finish your story when he came out on
radio and i heard him on radio i was
like who the hell is this guy
this is legit i was like yeah yeah
recently i guess he he felt like he's
not a he
or she so he wants to be uh they are
them and he got mad trying
no no he doesn't know that he didn't uh
get mad at him so it's just fans you
know fans are gonna be
the way they always are getting into
everyone's business online unlocked
which is yeah how dare you do this and
so shawn mendes was introducing
sam smith out of jingle ball so he goes
and he blah blah he just said he
accidentally right because
i didn't even know he was the they are
them though all right too many pronouns
too many pronouns but then so now was he
promoting that he
no he was uh what are you promoting is
he promoting the fact that he
identifies as he said it on some sort of
interview
i'm so sorry for referring to you as a
he for your jingle bell
your jingle bell introduction is
absolutely his name's sam though
yeah and he has a beard again so
but sam can be a woman true true very
true and sam can be a day
so there's there's sam smith my pronouns
are they them
i don't know when this was posted you
know uh
like the the the girl from juno is about
to say
she's she's trans elliot page now
elliott page where she is
yeah you got to call it what she looks
like i'll show you in a second
so sam just like it's before
it's the same yeah but you got to call
her
him elliot elliott yeah and don't [ __ ]
up
don't [ __ ] up do not [ __ ] because she
put that hat on he's the only difference
he he
so this is sam smith's post in september
2019. so he i guess he's announced that
he's a they are them
uh but then sam smith saw the apology
and then he wrote this
to sam to shawn mendes we're all
learning together
love love happy holidays all my love too
you know that's chromosomes
decoding i'm the zodiac okay
we're going down a weird path man
yeah yeah i think so as long as your
attention i don't think
um shawn mendes even wrote out what he
was supposed to say like there's a team
that kind of writes
a little script for you to read off of
when you introduce somebody
so i don't even know if those were sean
also sam smith
smith didn't feel any type of way what
has has the genitalia of a male has a
beard
his name is sam smith
how many times do people mess up what
origin of asian you are uh that's the
correct reason
yeah yeah that's correct yeah i did
visit years does it does it make you
[ __ ] go what the [ __ ] no i think
we're all
learning and it's one of those things
where it's like it's not that deep
either because no one ever
says like oh you're chinese with like uh
i don't know why i don't know why we i
don't know why we have to go so
so hard on a product but goes especially
when they are affected themselves
especially when they are offended
themselves sam smith didn't feel any
type of way about it
and i'm not like i'm just trying i'm
just trying to understand
more like why why the [ __ ] the
intents of like
yo [ __ ] you for that like why why did
this just like with like caitlyn
jenner caitlyn jenner how they got mad
right away like that's caitlyn
you refer to her and she it's like whoa
hold the [ __ ]
up since i was a child that was a man
named bruce
yeah and was on a wheaties box and was
all over the camera all up in the videos
as bruce jenner yeah so if i if
it takes me a while to adapt to her and
katelyn is that like you gotta give
people a transition that's what i was
doing what would the chance
people go so hard these people go so
hard as if it's someone's intentions
to affect that's what they spend that's
the thing that's like
now we need to we need a children yeah
yeah sean came out and was like all
right this dude
as they then but i'm gonna call him he
that's like whoa yeah yeah and that's
not what
uh sean mendes was doing it's like
that's what i'm saying like we we
we've it's so [ __ ] up in the head but
here's the thing only online
only online never mind just kidding yeah
you're right
no no no it's mind-boggling how people
go so hard like
he said they don't have anything to do
yeah and now everyone's locked out
everyone's upset everyone's broke
everyone's very frustrated with the
economy very frustrating
you know you know every time someone
calls me [ __ ] white
people call me white all the time on
facetime i remember my people yeah
people always
be white just because of my style
because i listen to this and i do these
things
people call me white all the [ __ ]
time what do you mean they call you
white what do you mean they call me why
they'll be like white chappelle
yeah you're so white you're so white
you're so white all the [ __ ] times
you got something meanwhile
oh but like but like the problem the
problem is you're comedian and on
it happens but it happens to me too
because because the king of the sting we
roast each other
so fans think that they have the green
thank you yeah
so it's it's no ill will when they're
like oh
white chappelle or thick brennan or you
know whatever they could but i'm saying
if we're talking online and the way
people go like people
online say that [ __ ] to me all the
[ __ ] now if your mom
or your dad got online or you know
whoever your close friend your girl gets
online
and doesn't know the context doesn't
know you do king the sting where it's a
rose show
you're like what the [ __ ] yeah my dad my
dad would be like what the [ __ ] you say
about my son like why are you getting
[ __ ] white you know what i mean like
but but like i'm not sitting here
you know going online like i [ __ ] you
know
listen all i say is i've never been
white yeah because i never have you know
what i mean but
but like i'm not gonna i don't wanna
uproar
about this [ __ ] i don't wanna uproar i
don't know it's just it's just wild to
like think that like
that's someone misinterpreted that's
because you have so much other [ __ ]
going on yeah
that's not even you don't even think
about that yeah because you're
successful and you have a lot of
you have bigger fish to fry yeah yeah
but they don't
those people online do not also you know
that's that's yeah i know myself well
but that's also
those people's issue which isn't sam
smith's issue
that's the biggest issue in their life
right now yeah
that's weird that someone someone else's
[ __ ] yeah is their issue
how the [ __ ] do you do that it's bro
that's [ __ ] wild
again it's society you have people that
go out and go do stuff
you guys just society or is it online
some make millions others make
memes um j cole i saw that your brother
would be so proud
i know i know yeah he would yeah you
know because j cole
performed in idaho that's where we
performed time out
that was jake's first text right i was
like he's like it's dope j
cole performing
[Applause]
lit what else you guys got what was that
saying you said it means some make memes
others make millions
oh okay that's good
um let's see let's go i thought this was
really cool
uh i have no idea what the story is but
the kid had a cleft you know lip
yeah and then with through surgery it
almost like perfectly fixed his face
that's awesome that's such a cute baby
yeah
this workout important it's incredible
yeah that's awesome how cool is that
that was how cool is that how cool is
that
oh hell yeah i appreciate that one and i
just saw this on tmz
this uh amazon driver parked his truck
i think it's him purchase truck sort of
in the middle of the lane where no one
can pass by him so he can just deliver
all of his uh packages the [ __ ] is wrong
i'll show you this how did tmz get this
[ __ ] i don't know
i'll move it for you no you're not
moving nothing i'm ready to drop these
packages off
look he's causing the shoes
i am talking to you like that right now
you hear me they all hear me
you inconsiderate piece of [ __ ] move the
[ __ ] truck are you safe
yeah you can [ __ ] off too
all right i'm gonna move it for you yeah
go get in the truck dude i bet he won't
do it i bet you he does
smiles on me you've got spars on me why
don't you spouse on the steering wheel
drop my [ __ ] off bro get out my facebook
dude move the van
you got like 20 people all y'all in my
[ __ ] ear about cooking your [ __ ]
truck bro
did you see the [ __ ] mess you're
causing bro i'm not [ __ ]
i'm just trying to deliver the packages
i don't give a [ __ ] pull over you [ __ ]
it is kind of you're in the middle you
really wouldn't move yeah on the street
multiple people i don't know you think
you're in the right way yeah you don't
give a [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ] when your ass is
fired i'm not going to get fired bro i'm
dropping
i thought he was on the side like you
know like no no no no
he's just stopped in the middle of
street that's messed up okay that's
[ __ ] up
did he get fired i don't know ups would
have never done that
[Laughter]
damn dude they're looking into the
incident
i just don't know why he wouldn't move
that's messed up yeah it's just so pull
it to the side
so it's selfish it's just so selfish wow
that's one of them young guns dog he
finally he probably got a job he don't
want to work
his mom was like bro you want to do
something i don't know how did someone
not move his car
he was well you're gonna you'll get in
trouble dude that's like grand theft if
you get in this car
and try to move it yeah at that point
though i i guarantee you if you copy
that
like dude he parked in the middle and
caused all the traffic jam the cop i bet
you wouldn't give you a ticket
but you don't want to risk it yeah you
don't i would want to do it but like
i would i would be busy i would risk it
because i would risk it i would move it
and like you ain't gonna do [ __ ] and i'd
get in my car and drive up okay but what
if amazon was like
well we need to get this person for
touching our car i mean that's a risky
take
yeah that's the risk i don't want to
take i mean you'd be so pissed off you'd
probably do it though because you i
would be so pissed off
i couldn't believe he really wouldn't
dude his attitude
pretty sure they will fire he's gonna
get fired yeah i don't know why that's
insane
if he doesn't get fired and then
everyone sees that he didn't get fired
after he did that i wouldn't
be on amazon is that working for me oh
yeah yeah he had no
he could he was not considerate jeff
bezos was going to call him
woody
you don't think he'd call him yeah he
would he was like well he made jeff
bezos with fire
he's like thank that guy's fired right
and i'm like yeah go ahead and let him
go
dave uh this is just a flamethrower on a
drone
to kill a wasp's nest in china that's
dope yeah
not that one i have the video somewhere
maybe it's over here
there it is
china makes the craziest check out oh my
god that's
insane that is so cool yep
we know a drone took out that uh
that politician in israel oh [ __ ]
or israel set it up yeah and it was a
drone with a machine gun
[ __ ] i pulled up this car drove off
that's all we killed that is a scary
thing about drones too yeah drones are
killing everybody
yeah it's all drones but yeah even small
drones they're scary now
man the world is crazy right yeah man
that's cool and there's also great
things in the world
yeah yeah man it's too bad all right
i don't know as much as there is bad
there is good
there's a lot of good yeah yeah that's
beautiful chapel it is
yeah because i hate when people try to
say all the world's a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] is going to end
it's like there's a lot of great clothes
what's this so i guess someone was
was selling her house for 400 000 and
banksy so i i don't know where he
uh did this graffiti i don't know if
it's like over a fence and then it's her
house
but apparently he drew on her house and
it upped
the house price to 6.6 million just
because banksy was a part of it
so of course she pulled out of the sale
that much
how do you verify that it's banksy and
not somebody trying to do his art style
you talking about a copycat
yeah it's tough to copy his [ __ ] yeah
that's right and he just does it pop up
yeah because nobody knows who banksy is
where's the house in england somewhere
london probably
to see that's a cool way to help
somebody
so that's why banksy posted about it
yeah oh he actually got it
to verify whoa that's cool the house
leaving
yeah i think it's like the picture right
yeah it's probably like san francisco no
it's just
like where like it's built on a hill but
they um level up so
dope oh got it okay
so it's actually leveled out yeah so he
did hop over some sort of fence right am
i tripping
now he hopped over there he jumped on
there i'm sure she's not mad at it no
not at all so that's cool so dope 6.6
million from 400 000. that's amazing
come paint my apartment dog
yeah come paint my truck
up that value what is the woman doing
let me see she's amazing sneezing
is that so that's for oh her teeth uh
fly out so is that covet
i don't know it might be i'm trying to
understand i'm worried
he's flying out just yeah she has like
dentures yeah
do you see that right now oh those did
you see that i didn't see that i'm
trying to see if somebody i thought you
meant all these little white things for
your teeth
no no it's a message in that art i'm
just trying to figure it out
yeah that's cool
that's cool be over it
oh good the sneeze knocked over every
building on the street like dominoes
that's the appearance it's supposed to
give but what is the teeth
like the dentures have to do with
anything just because she's older i
get it yeah oh what so uh
male you see on the right yeah with the
umbrella and it's like blowing yeah the
sneeze is what's blowing
mm-hmm and since they look if you tilt
the camera it's gonna look like
everything's tilted like dominoes
there though i was there i was trying to
figure it out because none of y'all was
doing helping me
yeah i was like oh cool you got it
though you got it i kept looking i kept
looking
shut up
yeah you got you all right
so this is good this is good uh airlines
in the us can now start to ban emotional
support animals
but of course dogs are still allowed but
other types of animals
oh god someone brought on like an
ostrich right or some [ __ ] yeah somebody
had like emotional support
peacock because an emotional support
animal can be any sort of animal as long
as you have the right paperwork
and that animal doesn't have to be
certified like a service dog has to be
certified
i don't give up and so some people want
like a weasel know they sometimes they
stink on the way over to the last trip
what was it i keep forgetting nashville
uh
someone had a dog like a labrador it
looks so cute but everyone had their
masks on so i couldn't
my girlfriend took the mask off to smell
real quick and she said it was
reeking the dog was reaching is that the
fight you didn't say hi to malecon
that's what he said he saw him
that's the one chin's all right
inviting the kids with friends
that's it all right that was fun man uh
this crew is in west palm beach close
out the year with us man west palm beach
florida
bring your tan asses there we had some
people reach out for those exotic cars
we'll be whipping around town
yeah and some lambos dms uh your healthy
food spots by the way
sure west palm beach december 31st
through january 2nd we will be there and
then san marcos just got added
san marcos texas we're outside austin
texas
january 29th through the 30th two shows
only limited capacity these [ __ ] will
sell out it's me
these boys some special guests san
martin very special guests
san marcos texas right outside austin
january 29th through the 30th tickets at
t5k.com
the thick boy smiley thick boy thick boy
merch smiley merch
drops this friday at midnight at
thickboy.com
we got tie-dye we got the new hats there
we got [ __ ] thick girl
thick girl sweats uh but the thick
smiley face
hoodies sweats and hats and tees dropped
this friday at midnight thickboy.com
let's go let's go
let's go let's go there i got the uh
merch man yeah that's chappelle lacey
merch love is tight look at all that
that one breaker oh chin you wanted to
win breakers yes please yeah i got you
i'll get you that thank you
actually what size are you large okay i
can't give you this one
i could fit a medium no i have a large i
have a large for you yeah yeah
i'll get you that but yeah go ahead and
get that and then malik b oh i got uh
you know my my t-shirts coming uh hot
coming in
hot you know i mean a lot of people
bought them and i sent them a snippet of
the little shine discs
so if you want to buy that
anyway we got six bigger queen merch on
the way so yeah
malik dribb.com all right kids we love
you we're out
matt you get a snippet i send you my new
track they're like no we don't want them